Joe Biden turns around a flailing
presidential campaign with a massive
showing on Super Tuesday whereas last
week Joe was dead both figuratively and
literally now he is only dead literally
we will examine what the establishment
comeback means for the Democratic
primary and for the general election
then the media are shocked that a
Hispanic could possibly vote for
president Trump disgraced throuple
congresswoman Katie hill teaches us all
a lesson on selfishness and Taylor Swift
hates men all that and more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
what a night last night on Super Tuesday
if you joined us for daily wire
backstage coverage we were there smoking
stogies and drinking whiskey for about
four and a half hours or so and the
results were largely what what we
predicted would happen on this show
yesterday which was that going into
Super Tuesday before the establishment
Democrats dropped out of the race before
Buddha judge and Klobuchar dropped out
and endorsed Joe Biden it looked like
Bernie was gonna kill it he was gonna
not quite sweep Super Tuesday but really
have a blowout and then after those
establishment candidates got out and you
saw all of the Democratic usual suspect
Susan Rice Harry Reid those kind of
people after all of them coalesced
within the course of about two days
behind Joe Biden when you just looked at
the poll averages and you added on that
extra establishment support all of a
sudden they completely flipped it looked
like Joe was gonna blow it out and and
that's basically what happened we've now
got a final delegate count I mean the
delegates are still coming in but Final
Four Wednesday morning after Super
Tuesday of about 450 or 453 to about 380
for Bernie Sanders so you've got about a
70 point lead now 70 delegate lead for
Joe Biden that's like a commanding lead
the third place is Elizabeth Warren
she's only got about 50 delegates as of
right now and then everybody has even
fewer after that so this is now
certainly a two-person race and it's
probably going to be a race to the
convention so Joe Biden won Alabama
Arkansas Massachusetts Minnesota North
Carolina Oklahoma Tennessee Texas and
Virginia Texas is a big win here because
the the two big prizes on Super Tuesday
or Texas in California just in terms of
population it looked a week ago like
Bernie was gonna win Texas then Joe
turned it around it was a very very
tight so it's not like each of these
states was a blowout and I think the
tightness of that is going to really
matter at the convention because
the one thing that the Democrats do they
rigged up the whole primary right
they've got a group of people called
super-delegates who are just these party
elites who come in doesn't matter what
the voters vote for they're gonna come
in and choose whoever they want in a
smoke-filled back room at the convention
and the super-delegates account for
about 16 percent of the total delegates
who are going to decide who the nominee
is but to offset that what the Democrats
do in their voting is proportional
voting so it's not like they just come
in and a winner takes all in in the
state and so you know if you win the
state 51 to 49 all of a sudden you get a
hundred percent of the delegates
actually it's proportional so if you win
fifty-one percent of the state you might
get fifty-one percent of the delegates
what that does is drag out the
convention fight all the way all the way
until the DNC so if it were a normal
candidate that was running against Joe
Biden now you might see as Joe Biden's
lead begins to grow you might see that
candidate consider dropping out of the
race but Bernie Sanders is not a normal
candidate we we read Bernie Sanders as
sex manifestos about the revolution from
the late 1960s and early 70s this is not
your run-of-the-mill establishment dem
he's not gonna fall in line he's about
three hundred fifty years old so it's
not like he's gonna get a whole lot more
opportunities to run for president all
he's done for his entire life is be a
political activist and run for office so
this is kind of it for him he is gonna
drag it out it's gonna get very very
bloody and Bernie did get a big state
win last night he got California and in
addition to that he got Colorado Utah
and Vermont and as of writing this show
Maine was still up in the air so the
delegate count pretty pretty clear now
Joe Biden is up in the lead and boy
those Democrats dodged a bullet for now
we will explain why first I've got to
thank our friends over at stamps.com I
am a millennial I don't want to leave my
chair if I don't have to leave my chair
I don't want to have to go interact with
the physical world if I can do things
virtually stamps.com is great for me it
is completely online so you don't need
make special trips to the post office or
or or you know head on out and have to
wait online and all this no stamps calm
you save five cents off every first
class stamp and up to 40% off shipping
rates and that can really add up you
just use your computer to for an
official u.s. postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
if you are living in the 21st century
you got to go to stamps calm okay
this it isn't like the 1950s anymore go
it makes your life so much easier
stamps calm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in Noel's
that stamps.com click the microphone
enter Canada wles alright
Democrats dodged a real bullet here so
President Trump wants Bernie Sanders
alright president Trump is hoping that
Bernie gets the nomination he did you
know President Trump he just he just
tweeted this out I'll read the tweet
straight straight from his account he
president Trump as this all comes out he
says the Democrat establishment came
together and crushed Bernie Sanders
again even the fact that Elizabeth
Warren stayed in the race was
devastating to Bernie and allowed sleepy
Joe to unthinkably win Massachusetts it
was a perfect storm with many good
states remaining for Joe he keeps going
so selfish for Elizabeth Warren to stay
in the race she has zero chance of even
coming close to winning but hurts Bernie
badly so much for their wonderful
liberal friendship will he ever speak to
her again she cost him Massachusetts and
came in third
he shouldn't I love him so much so much
this is one of trumps superpowers right
is that he's very very good at
television he understands how to create
drama tension characters that's part of
what the nicknaming is about is so that
these politicians who seem kind of stiff
or or whatever
they then come to feel like television
characters that you would know you turn
on the TV and it's Archie Bunker or
somebody except instead of Archie Bunker
it's sleepy Joe I guess actually in that
analogy Trump is probably the more
Archie Bunker like character but you you
know sleepy Joe you know crooked Hillary
you know crazy Bernie and it's all about
these personal relationships Trump is
very very good about having a
relationship with the voters and about
describing and pulling out the
relationships between all of these other
politicians because don't forget the guy
was the king of the reality TV so when
he's trying to boost Bernie and go after
by to create some chaos in the
Democratic primary he doesn't just say
socialism is bad
socialism is gonna kill us all we're
gonna have bread lines he doesn't do
that no but I mean that maybe that works
once or twice but that that falls flat
eventually what people are interested in
is the personal narrative the personal
story so instead he says all those
Democrats they're conspiring to steal it
from poor Bernie right he's actually
making Bernie into this kind of
sympathetic figure
and I thought Liz Warren was his friend
that woman backstabbed her own friend he
should never speak to her again what do
you all think do you think he's gonna
speak to her again
also personal and he has a point on
Massachusetts Elizabeth Warren was the
front-runner in the Democratic Party
what two three months ago now she's
nothing she's not winning anything part
of that is because she we saw her when
you see more of Elizabeth Warren her
support tends to go down but she lost
Massachusetts and Joe Biden got it you
know same thing in Minnesota Minnesota
is where Amy Klobuchar is from Amy
Klobuchar was at the top of the pack in
Minnesota until she dropped out of the
race
the second was Bernie Sanders so if Amy
had maybe got another race much earlier
or if she stuck in it even Bernie
Sanders would have had a better night
there compared to Joe Biden instead Joe
Biden picked that up too so President
Trump I think pretty clearly wants
Bernie Republicans generally want Bernie
there's
slight disagreement on this we had it
last night on the backstage show which
is some Republicans some conservatives
like me like drew Clavin they want
Bernie because one Trump is going to win
57 states plus Greenland plus American
Samoa which is the only area that Mike
Bloomberg won but he'll win everything
if it's against Bernie I think the
polling bears that out very well I think
they've got an apple file on him that's
very very long the other reason is it's
an honest fight you know Bernie actually
stands for something he stands for
socialism and Donald Trump is a symbol
of American free enterprise and you're
gonna have that battle and it's gonna be
hilarious to watch so I'm all for that
that is the sort of upside view right
you're looking at how great it'll be
when Trump wins the other view which
which Ben and Jeremy have we were
talking about it on backstage is the
downside view they say look even if
Trump is more likely to beat Bernie
Sanders I still would rather Joe Biden
be the nominee because I don't want the
whole Democratic Party to unify behind
Bernie Sanders an actual socialist and
old commie and I don't want to risk the
chance that Bernie somehow becomes
president me I'm not so afraid of the
risk bring on the risk I am I'm not
terribly risk-averse
I think it'd be great to have the honest
conversation and I think it'll feel even
better to win this time then it felt
last time so you got Trump you got most
Republicans want Bernie the Democrats
pretty clearly want Biden okay the
reason they want Biden is because one I
think they know that Bernie is more
likely to get completely blown out of
the race but two I'm not sure that they
want this guy this socialist coming in
and taking over their party don't forget
Bernie Sanders isn't even a registered
Democrat so Bernie isn't been an
independent and he describes himself as
a socialist then in 2016 in order to run
for the Democratic primary he had to
register as a Democrat which he did then
he lost that primary Jiri registers as
an independent this time around so that
his Bernie bro supporters
didn't have a complete meltdown they
allowed him to run as an independent but
he's actually technically not even a
Democrat so the party itself the party
apparatus really doesn't like the guy
they keep trying to rob him they
probably are successfully gonna rob him
again
and Biden is in the lead but Biden still
faces challenges so last night by Dhin
is addressing his supporters he's so
happy he's so excited everyone's feeling
great and he confuses his wife with his
sister all right so this is this was
actually a pretty funny moment I think
for a guy who's been plagued on the
campaign trail by forgetting all sorts
of things a couple days ago he forgot
the name of God in the Declaration of
Independence we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all you know and and
you know the thing so he he lost that
he's messed up people's names he's done
all of that I don't think that's what's
really happening in this clip I think
he's staring forward at the crowd he's
got two women on either side when he's
not looking at either of them so he
reaches for one he says this is my
sister oh wait a minute that's not my
sister all done you guys turned around
on me it was kind of a funny moment it
showed he was a little more with it
maybe than that than we had seen before
the bigger challenge I think look Joe
Biden is nothing he is a truly an empty
suit he's the embodiment of nothing
what's really gonna happen now is as it
looks like Joe's walking away with the
nomination these radical Democrats and
there are many of them are going to
create a lot of trouble for him they
already did that last night Joe's big
happy victory speech was interrupted by
activists not just any kind of activists
they were activists protesting the
horrible cruelty of milk
[Music]
[Applause]
let's say let dari die that is an actual
campaign if if you had taken this to a
an SNL screenwriter five years ago no
one would have believed it right nobody
would have believed it but that's where
we are now I mean this is that Joaquin
Phoenix tough this is that Joaquin
Phoenix at the Oscars comes up he goes
look man we've got to stop drinking milk
we got to stop eating cheese it's so
cruel it's so awful by the way all of
these people support abortion they also
work killing babies in the womb but they
don't want to drink milk because somehow
it's mean to the cow I don't think Joe
Biden is particularly worried about the
dairy industry but there are a lot of
grassroots leftists who are going to
come up and make a lot of trouble for
Joe Biden as this goes on we will get to
the the rest of the night we will get to
the radicalism of the party first I got
to thank our friends over at Tommy John
look I am a man who has simple tastes I
am easily satisfied by the very best as
Winston Churchill said Tommy John is the
revolutionary clothing brand that has
redefined comfort for Americans
everywhere Tommy John is all about
fabric fit and function Tommy John
obsesses over every little detail and
stitch by using proprietary fabrics that
perform like nothing you have ever worn
before
as a result Tommy John's men's and
women's underwear sport a very
comfortable guarantee stay put
waistbands a range of fabrics that are
luxuriously soft feather-light moisture
wicking breathable and designed to move
with you not against you it is by far
the best I've ever worn Tommy John is so
confident in their underwear that if you
don't love your first pair you can get a
full refund with their best pair you'll
ever wear or it's free guarantee you can
also find them in over 1,200 retail
locations across the country including
Nordstrom stores Tommy John no
adjustment needed but you don't need to
go to those stores go to Tommy John comm
/ Knowles Keo wles for 20% off
first order Tommy John comm / Knowles
20% off your first order Tommy John comm
/ Knowles Bernie did not have a terrible
night he had an OK night his supporters
are going to say that this whole thing
is rigged this time around it doesn't
seem like it's quite rigged it seems
like it's strategic right it seems like
the the Democratic Party is making a
choice here so the person who most
underperformed is Warren does that fan
question just came in from TZ who is the
next drop out funny you should ask that
now very likely could be Warren there
it's either Warren or Bloomberg right
and so Warren had a terrible night I
mean it was humiliating she came in
third in her own State so for war and
the question is gonna be can she go to
her donors with a straight face and say
give me more of your money so that I can
do what I can't even win Massachusetts
no probably not and the Elizabeth Warren
needs those donors because she's still
running she's still an active politician
Mike Bloomberg doesn't need any of that
money he's accountable to no one and
he's got his campaign staff on contract
through November so Mike Bloomberg
didn't cost him anything really to keep
running the guys worth 60 billion
dollars so even if he spends another 200
million that doesn't really do all that
much if Elizabeth Warren is smart for
the rest of her career she will drop out
now and stop burning her her donor money
Mike Bloomberg doesn't have to worry I
hope he stays in a long time and pushes
for a brokered convention and buys off
the whole rest of party so Elizabeth
Warren's big problem why did she flop
her big problem was she didn't pick a
lane the lane was do you go for Bernie's
voters or biden's voters all right this
is this is a problem that rhinos have a
lot the Republicans in name only write
is why would you vote for a liberal
Republican when you can vote for a
Democrat this was Elizabeth Warren's
problem she when she initially issues
maybe gonna go for some of Biden's
voters then she
decided she was gonna go radical go for
Bernie's voters and then when she was
asked more or less why should people
vote for you over Bernie she said look I
love Bernie's policies I think they're
great
Bernie is so terrific but I'll be better
at implementing them nobody cares about
that nobody is gonna get behind that
candidate if you're making the argument
that you're just Bernie light if
Republicans make the argument that
they're Democrats light then people are
gonna vote for the real thing why do I
want this watered-down watered-down
Bernie Sanders when I can get the real
Bernie why would anybody vote for some
weak Republican who's half a Democrat
when they can just vote for the Democrat
themselves another lane that she didn't
pick which is people are not really
talking about is that there are two
kinds of politicians there are
conviction politicians and convenience
politicians I've been saying this for a
long time dennis prager brought it up
last night on the backstage those are
the two that can the politicians who
believe something who run for office to
do something to enact a vision and
politicians who just want to be
politicians now when you look at the two
Democratic frontrunners it's pretty
clear who is who
Bernie Sanders got to give the guy
credit where credit's due he's had a
consistent vision Joe Rogan called
Bernie's vision insanely consistent I
would call it insane as well Joe Biden
doesn't believe in anything he's changed
his opinion on virtually every issue he
doesn't care he is a cynical view of the
world he has no regard for the truth he
just wants to be a politician he just
wants to be the president he wants to
sit in the Oval Office so those are the
two and you can pick right actually both
kinds of politicians can be successful
Liz Warren's trouble is she can't decide
which is she gonna be
she is cynical she has no regard for the
truth she lies about everything her
upbringing her getting fired her child
school all of that but is she gonna be
the progressive champion the fighter
power to the people or is she gonna be
an establishment Arian DC type person
who really knows how to work the system
she didn't choose and it was too bad for
her Mike Bloomberg lost everything
except for American Samoa the thing that
matters is not Bloomberg's campaign
because he not gonna be president the
thing that matters is it shows you how
empty a left-wing slogan is the left is
always telling you that people are
buying off the White House they're
buying political office in the United
States Mike Bloomberg sure doesn't think
so
Bloomberg's candidacy shows you money
doesn't actually determine politics in
the United States the guy has spent like
six hundred million dollars so far he's
spent over half a billion dollars on
this campaign and he's gotten nowhere
other than American Samoa which he could
have just purchased outright for the
same amount of money the left is always
prattling on about Citizens United
the Supreme Court decision that allowed
people to donate to candidates that
allowed organizations to donate to
candidates as you absolutely should be
permitted to do they said there's too
much money in politics even John McCain
when he teamed up with all the liberals
on one of the occasions that he teamed
up with all the Liberals he limited our
First Amendment rights to donate to
political campaigns he said there's too
much money in politics
guess what money in politics doesn't go
very far does it Mike Bloomberg
completely flopped guys got all the
money in the world actually we've seen
this before we saw this in the 1992
election with Ross Perot Ross Perot was
an independent billionaire who came out
spent a lot a lot of money didn't do
anything didn't go very far at all the
enduring image from the day from the
Bloomberg campaign comes out it is Mike
Bloomberg at a table of snacks reaching
and grabbing the snacks and licking all
of his fingers then reaching back into
the snack so you see this he looks just
like a he looks like an old retired
billionaire really he's wearing a
sweater kind of hunched over doing
whatever he wants licking his fingers
like a total psycho then lean it then
back in he's touching the coffee thing
look man we got coronavirus over here
this is not terribly sanitary and it
doesn't look good doesn't make you look
like a leader so the Super Tuesday
leaves Democrats in relatively good
shape with Biden they have a chance
however small to be
President Trump so that's good I guess
they're probably breathing a sigh of
relief their downside is it's now more
likely to be a very very bloody primary
all the way to the convention whereas if
it were Bernie it might not have been so
bloody because if Bernie actually made
it through he probably would have run
away with the thing maybe more important
than the number of Delegates that each
candidate got is the number of voters
who actually showed up I think this is
going to predict a little bit more than
even the horse race of who's winning
Democratic turnout so far in this
primary is down it's down from 2018
which was a midterm election we were
told every all the Democrats are fired
up they're gonna show up they're gonna
go at the young voters fired up young
voters barely turned out NBC was
reporting from exit polls thirteen
percent of the voters were young I
thought young voters were gonna make up
the majority that's what they all told
us a Virginia turnout was pretty high
most other places very low at the same
time president Trump is seeing record
high turnout for an incumbent so in New
Hampshire just use that example Trump
got about a hundred thirty thousand
votes in the Republican 2020 primary
most people don't even know that there
are people running against Donald Trump
in the Republican primary but there are
one in guy's name is Bill weld a couple
other wackos and Trump Trump got the
voters out it crushed them got 130,000
votes that's more than double what Obama
got in 2012 when he was running for
re-election and what George Bush got in
2004 when he was running for re-election
the media can't understand this okay
they can't understand why Democrats
would not be totally fired up ready to
go to the polls of for the ouster of
President Trump and why anybody would
still go vote for Trump so there was
this great moment it happened on MSNBC
or one of the reporters asked a Hispanic
man who he was voting for who his family
was voting for and she did get the
answer that she liked we will get to
that in a second but first I've got to
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube The
Daily wires own Andrew Clavin you
offered of that guy I think you know him
he's released the second entry in his
another Kingdom trilogy
the books are just tremendous they're
really terrific I've had the privilege
of narrating them from the beginning so
season one we started three years ago we
did it up in Drew's attic and then it
jumped up became one of the top arts
podcasts in the world then we got our
second third season out of it
I'm also narrating the audio book so
we're gonna go into the studio for that
next week the second book is great it's
called the nightmare feast and this
trilogy is really weird in the sense
that the first one is good very popular
sold a lot of copies people really liked
it the second one is better the third
one is the best of all but you can't
read the third until you read the second
one so I would go head on out that is
the nightmare feast part of the another
Kingdom trilogy by Andrew Clavin head on
over to Daly wire.com
you know what you get you get all of us
you get all the shows you get everything
and you get the leftist here's tumblr
which is so so important so head on over
to Daly wire.com slash subscribe we'll
be right back with a lot more
all right so the media are shocked they
can't imagine that enthusiasm might be a
little lower for Democrats might
actually be pretty high for Republicans
so on Kate Eaters show on MSNBC she goes
in with an interpreter to talk to a man
at a Hispanic market and they ask who
they're voting for
she doesn't like the economy you don't
see that too much but it's fascinating
you know and Latino community you're
seeing that there's still kind of this
stubborn 10 to 15 percent of the
population that is gonna that
continuously polls in favor of Donald
that is you know at least in my family
look I don't know some folks or members
of law enforcement some folks you know
just really focus on the economy
I don't know what the exact reasons are
but there tends to be that Stern
conservative flank within the Latino
community I love this I love his is
embarrassed he's embarrassed for his own
community says yeah there's just this
really stubborn 15% that had votes for
Trump and Republicans I don't get I
don't get it right he asks the guys is
wait who's your daughter voting for I
says uh for Trump for Donald for Donald
listen.you that familiarity that first
name and so he said why and she goes
yeah if she likes him I don't know she
likes him and you know the economy is
good and whatever and and then this guy
says wait hold on there's this stubborn
group of Hispanics who are oh maybe they
work in law enforcement maybe they like
it when there are laws and there's there
a stable country and I guess they like
the economy what a bunch of weirdos they
don't even understand about the 56
genders they don't even care about
gender theory and killing babies they
don't it's like so weird right it
doesn't make sense they can't figure it
out I think most Americans have figured
it out now let's get to a listener
question from MJ Michael do you think
the closer the race is the more it hurts
Biden in the general election because
all the Bernie bros will stay home and
Election Day feeling they got cheated
yes it's very possible it's very
possible that they will not show up you
know usually what happens in bruising
primaries is the party comes together
they unite it's fine
don't worry about it the thing that's
different about Bernie Sanders thing
that might have been different about
Donald Trump too is they're not regular
members of their own parties I mean
Bernie Sanders is literally not a
Democrat and Donald Trump was not a
Republican for much of his life so he
got different voters in that usually you
know the Republicans wouldn't get in for
Bernie that usually the Democrats
wouldn't get and they just want Bernie
they don't want Biden they hate Biden if
you look at the vitriol that that the
Bernie bros have sent at Biden at Budaj
edge even at Elizabeth Warren these kind
of neoliberal establishment types I
think they probably prefer Donald Trump
and I think that's what Trump is
thinking Trump is thinking I could win
over
Berni guys and even if I can't win them
all over I can demoralize them enough or
rather Joe Biden is gonna demoralize
them enough that they'll stay home
because they don't hate me all that much
more than they hate Joe Biden in some
cases they probably prefer him so you've
got this bruising primary that's going
on and that's really what I think the
Republicans are hoping for they're
hoping for like the iran-iraq war you
don't care who wins you just want you
just want mass casualties some Democrats
have gone from perplexed at this to
furious and one of them is the former
head of the Democratic Party Donna
Brazile who's a contributor on Fox News
she was interviewed on Fox News and she
was on with Ronnie McDaniel who's the
head of the Republican Party currently I
just did an event with her at CPAC and
Ron is kind of laughing and having a
great time about this crazy Democratic
primary and Donna Brazile gets so heated
and she tells the RNC chairwoman to go
to hell I want to talk to my Republicans
first of all stay the hell out of our
race stay the hell out of our race I get
sick and tired and Sandra I've listened
to Republicans tell me and the Democrats
about our process first of all they
don't have a process they're cancelling
primaries they have winner-take-all they
don't have the kind of democracy that we
see on the Democratic side and for
people to use Russian talking points
they're so division among Americans that
is stupid so Ronna go to hell
this is not about no go to hell I'm
tired of it ad we're not we're not
trying to prevent anyone from becoming
the nominee I know the process we're on
a nose to process but to infer that
we're trying to prevent one candidate
over another that's not happening okay
first of all that's not what in Furman's
there were I know there are other big
aspects of this this interview but this
is the first thing that jumped out at me
she means imply imply is when you are
saying something and that has an
insinuation and infer is when you are
deducing something from what you've
heard just
a minor point to show you that Donna
Brazile doesn't know what she's talking
about on a whole host of things because
she's being very dishonest in this clip
she she says that the Democrats are not
trying to steal this election from
anybody they are they don't want Bernie
to be the nominee that's why they all
coalesced behind Joe Biden after South
Carolina that's why they didn't even
wait until Super Tuesday but it's not
just that they're trying to steal it
from him now the way that I know that
Donna Brazile is lying about this is she
personally tried to steal the election
the nomination from Bernie Sanders in
2016
personally there was a democratic debate
and Donna Brazile passed debate
questions along to Hillary Clinton Donna
Brazile head of the DNC goes on cable
news a lot hands it to the candidate so
yes she is certainly stealing it from
them and then just think about how rude
it is think about how unseemly it is to
go out there and say hey you go to hell
this is dumb this is stupid this is
right they criticize Trump for being
mean and for being crass and for being
vulgar
that's very vulgar behavior that's
that's just as bad as anything that
Donald Trump has done but the left is
always projecting onto others what they
themselves do and then when occasionally
Trump actually fights fire with fire
gives them a taste of their own medicine
they're shocked they clutch their pearls
the fury that you're seeing from Donna
Brazile there is genuine I think I think
it is representative of what the
Democratic Party is feeling right now I
think they feel lost because even though
they dodged a bullet with Bernie last
night he didn't run away with Super
Tuesday they're in for a very bruising
primary process and their frontrunner
Joe Biden is simply past his prime okay
Joe Biden is in his late 70s he was not
always quick on his feet even in his 40s
or 50s he's been in the government for
about 50 years that's not a great look
when you when you look at somebody like
President Trump if you're trying to beat
the president this is a guy who he jokes
he says do I do I think Joe's too all
I don't know but I'm young and vibrant
I've got a lot of energy I mean Trump
has the energy of a guy who's half of
his age and Joe Biden does not he's got
the energy of a guy who's double his age
so I think they're really furious the
cream of the crop candidates did not
show up in 2020 that might be because
they're writing off the year and they're
going to try to regroup for 2024 in any
case a fine night for Democrats but a
finer primary season for Republicans
speaking of corrupt Democrats
misunderstanding the world there is a
little little reported on story here
that I thought was so indicative of the
kind of left-wing worldview so you
remember Katie Hill Katie Hill is that
democratic congresswoman who had the
throuple she was the one who was married
but then she was taking weird nude
photos with her staffer and combing her
hair and it was just like yucky it's
just not cool and then she was she had
relationships with other staffers and it
was just very very creepy and weird so
so Katie hill does all of this then it's
found out right that she's sleeping with
her staff and doing sort of things that
if a Republican did it they'd be run out
of town and probably prosecuted but
Katie Hill does it she's a Democrat and
the media conspire to paint her as a
victim somehow she's sexually harassing
all of her staff but she's the victim
and there's a lot of evidence that they
were actually planning this all out
together the media and Katie Hill so
there is now a piece trying to
rehabilitate her image this piece is out
in the cut you know it's a left-wing
outlet and it gets to I don't even
really care that much about Katie Hill
she can have whatever career she wants
it gets to a problem with the the way
the left used life and use the world
this is how it goes
by mid 2019 Hill was thriving in her new
role in Congress she'd begun a romantic
relationship with Alex Thomas a
political writer she met in DC in August
they went on a beach vacation together
there was over this overwhelming sense
then that like this is perfect she said
I feel so happy and I feel like I've
accomplished so much and I'm doing this
important work and like it can't really
get better than this and maybe this is
the point that I should just check out
right
check out meaning kill herself she's
married by the way and she's on this
vacation with a guy who's not her
husband goes on
she said she stared at the ocean and
thought of the awakening by Kate Chopin
a feminist novel from the turn of the
20th century in which a dissatisfied
wife and mother commits suicide by
drowning out very romantic dramatic
scene Katie hill contemplated suicide
very sad sort of thing hope she doesn't
do that hope she comes to her senses
what's most disturbing about this though
it's not even that she contemplated
suicide it's that she didn't contemplate
suicide when things were going really
really poorly she contemplated suicide
when things were going really really
well she said she writes I just felt so
happy I feel like I've accomplished so
much I'm doing this important work so I
can't really get better than this so
maybe this is the point I should just
kill myself she she thinks of suicide as
a way to celebrate how well things are
going and look at this important she
said I'm doing all this important work
but if you're doing all this important
work this work that you think is really
important why would you kill yourself
that would prevent you from doing the
work well we see here that Katie Hill
and I think a lot of leftists view them
their work this way what's important
about the work is not the effect it
might have on other people what's
important to her about the work is how
it makes her feel it's all just about
her the work makes me feel so good and
pleasure is all that I want this is what
happens to a mind that is warped by
selfishness is pleasure becomes the most
important thing to attain and if you
look at the personal scandals Katie Hill
has had you see that she's clearly lived
her life that way pleasure is the most
important thing and you have to
sacrifice everything including your own
life on the altar of pleasure she I just
want to feel good I just write I mean if
you look at this in the sort of sexual
realm you say oh good I've got this one
sexual partner that's go
maybe two would be better maybe three
would be even better than that and if
you look at this in the span of a
lifetime you say gosh I never want to
suffer I never want to go through pain I
never want to complete the work that I'm
saying is so important because if I
complete the work I will risk discomfort
and that would be unthinkable
unimaginable to possibly suffer at all
so instead I'm gonna just find the exact
moment when my pleasure levels are
exactly at the highest and then end it
that's really perverse I mean suicide is
a purely selfish act and that's true
even if you're in great pain and you
commit suicide that's surely selfish Act
but it but think about how much more
disturbing it is how much more perverted
your worldview has to be how much more
selfish you have to be to to contemplate
that because things are going too good
and you don't want them to get any worse
really perverse stuff but that's that's
what happens when your worldview just
goes off kilter
before we go speaking of world views
going off kilter I got to get to the
t-swift music video the news cycle has
been so insane we haven't had any time
to get to it but Taylor Swift does a new
video out that's called the man I think
and in it Taylor Swift very disturbingly
puts on all these prosthetics and looks
like a man and then sings about how
terrible men are and how it would be so
much cooler if she were a man so she's
got the suit on she'd be in a big jerk
ripping up things in the office
[Music]
so then she's she's sitting on the
subway dressed like a man with her legs
spread smoking a cigar which is actually
the way that I ride the subway
[Music]
if I were a man than I'd be the man
that's the that's the thesis and at one
point she he is urinating on the wall of
a subway there right this guy's a real
jerk huh this guy's a real jerk there
are so many problems with the logic of
this video first the first one has to do
with the thesis if I were a man then I'd
be the man because that doesn't plain
paint a very flattering portrait of
Taylor Swift she's saying if I were a
man then I would be the man she's saying
all these terrible qualities associated
with this guy that I'm describing I have
all of those qualities but because I'm a
woman
they reflect really poorly on me but if
I were a man they would reflect really
good on me right if I were a man I'd be
the man so she's saying she's
promiscuous and a jerk because that's
how she's depicting the man in this
video and of course in reality that's
that's not the way it's worked out in
reality Taylor Swift is portrayed in a
very flattering way and the man in this
video the stereotypical man in that
video was portrayed in a very negative
way including by Taylor Swift the second
problem here
she undercuts her whole thesis by
showing that she wouldn't be the man
right the whole thing is if I were a man
I people would love me for being a big
jerk at urinating on subways smoking
cigars and an opening and smoking cigars
in people's faces and opening my legs
and just being a yelling at people but
she's showing she wouldn't she wouldn't
be the man then because people don't
like those things and the way we know
they don't like those things is she's
using all of them to create a negative
portrait an unflattering portrait so she
wouldn't be the man the third problem
with the logic of this video is my
favorite one which is that by the logic
of the left she could be a man she may
be she is a man I like by the by the
current gender Theory logic that is
embraced by the mainstream left if you
are a woman and you want to be a man you
just can be or you then you are if you
put on a suit and you know you put on a
tie yeah then you're a man if you say
you're a man then you are a man so why
not just be a
man the video is undercutting of course
this whole logic of gender theory which
is that there's no such thing as gender
and of course if you're gonna make a
commentary on men and women then you
can't really go along with the gender
theory that there's no such thing as men
or women or the men can be women and
vice versa
not a very logical video what it is is
an emotional cry it's an emotional
temper tantrum and it comes from a place
of selfishness it's Taylor Swift saying
mmm life's not fair to me I'm a woman
Taylor Swift is incredibly wealthy
incredibly hot incredibly successful she
can do whatever she wants in life she
has had but she's got one of the most
privileged lives on earth but it's not
enough
you got a complain that's what happens
in a culture where everyone is just
whining for more and more more and me me
me whether it's T Swift or Katy hill or
or the fury that we're seeing in a
Democratic primary that's our show we
got a whole lot more but we'll have to
wait I'm gonna be filling in for the
bench bureau radio show today so you can
tune in to that I'm gonna be up at UC
Santa Cruz giving a speech that I'm
gonna fly out to right after the radio
show so hopefully my flights not delayed
and let's see you there that's gonna be
a fun speech on when democracy goes
wrong should be fun on I believe the
most liberal campus in the United States
so stay tuned we're gonna be streaming
that um I think the Daily wire and young
America's Foundation so check it out in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin Fenderson hair
and makeup
nikka geneva production assistant ryan
love the michael knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin hosted
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]